authorities in Northern California today
delivered the news that many women had
waited a quarter century to hear there
is an arrest in the NorCal rapist case
the suspect is a married man who's been
hiding in plain sight
why didn't I tell the community that
there was someone running around killing
girl they said he's only killing hookers
[Music]
oh hey everybody its episode 111 yeah
now please forgive me in advance because
we're recording this on Sunday afternoon
we're at a party and yeah our friends
Angela and Mike threw a birthday party
for me tonight
at their house and got out of control it
did kind of they had one of those things
set up at the back where you can jump in
there and jump have like a bounce house
yeah you inflate it and you can get up
in there they were trying to get me in
there you got on the stripper pole
though had a stripper pole in the house
[Laughter]
we drank a great deal and evidently
somebody's gonna jump in swimming pool
yeah had a bar in the house yeah I like
a house that I got a bar in it yeah we
left we left a couple fifths of booze
behind to as a gift yeah had Kayla there
hell yeah they did they had some of that
patron yeah so I was partaking in patron
yeah yeah well yeah so I'm just saying
I'm gonna try and keep my [ __ ] say so
mama day some woman brought some food
okay it was at reductant a turducken
turducken with crab legs sticking off of
it and a big tail made out of sausage
she had it hooked up look just like one
of the facehuggers from she opened it up
that was like my face hugger sitting in
there and I smelled that crab boil
coming out of there man it was it was it
was good though
I had some of that tail I drank so much
that it look gross oh man it looked like
that damn thing out of dad shepherd's
pie their brownies and all pineapple
upside-down cake instead I'm like oh
yeah I'm sitting there talking about my
diet yeah it's like we got there fairly
early and it's just like I was like oh
I'll have a couple drinks and you know
make rounds and talk and stuff and then
I'll eat later and by the time I it was
like four hours had passed and I was
like really drunk and I didn't need
anything I think I one chip with Thomas
yeah I got [ __ ] up talking about Tom
Baker doctor who going on and on about
each episodes or robots of death and the
talents of Wang Qiang and they're
looking at me with their mouths up never
the [ __ ] I'm talking about I'm fighting
over Doctor Who grown man fighting over
Tom Baker that's right defense a table
beggar that's like the whole of YouTube
is dudes man child I can't control it
and you know I mean I would have
actually kind of liked to have had a
drink for this episode going to but I'll
probably just Falls
yeah I'm just gonna try to just we're
very tired but hopefully this will be an
entertaining show
what's this episode about you're
actually doing this is two requests and
we've had this requested multiple times
we're doing the NorCal rapist which is
also the news
because I don't know if you guys know
and we're doing another serial killer
that I had never heard of and somebody
requested it the Grim Sleeper okay so
yeah we're gonna do those two okay so I
think it'll be you all right chest
burster that [ __ ] face of yours
that's what happens when you when you
eat a turducken that makes if you don't
know if we have some foreigners in there
no way you might have some people from
Yugoslavia and all these weird Eastern
European countries they may not know
what a traduction is it's a turkey
inside of a duck inside of a chicken no
no how does it go her weight as a
tourism what's the biggest thing the
Turk it's a turkey so it's a turkey with
a duck with a chicken inside that it's
cooked together but this one had action
and then this had pieces of crab coming
out with crab legs and a big tail made
out of sausage yeah sitting in a bright
red pool like blood but it was crab boil
and that date isn't [ __ ] that was weird
like it was cheese involved in there
somehow you know trying to get some crab
out of it the leg was cold though but
yeah so okay give you trouble
yeah so let's do like a couple of little
shout outs one thing that I wanted to
say that hopefully you guys will find
this exciting we just yesterday I signed
up for a shutter subscription yeah
shudder which is the it's kind of like
Netflix but it's a show to shout out
yeah but it's all horror movies and
thrillers and stuff like that and it's
only five bucks a month yeah it's worth
it
yeah because like I've been rolling
through there I'm like holy [ __ ] like a
whole bunch of the movies that were on
the list to review for the show we're on
there and then plus it was a [ __ ] ton of
other ones Azam's all the mix offices
yeah I think didn't have phantasm - but
no but it had all the other ones that
had
yeah well we watched phantasm 3
yesterday it was good yeah yeah but um
we're gonna do a review of phantasm 3 I
guess worth of review yeah yeah it's a
good food for thought and I'm talking
Tom shitty movies on Facebook all you
know drop some [ __ ] if you're able to
meet my stringent standards of going on
Tom shitty movies because it's close to
big s big yeah but yeah it's like I
honestly it's I wanted to see like what
kind of [ __ ] they had before I paid I
mean I know it's only five dollars a
month but still but the selection is
really good they have initiated a whole
[ __ ] yeah they have a [ __ ] ton of like
giallo movies they have all kind of
really good stuff and they you know they
have a lot of classics like they have a
whole collection like from the 80s they
have like old slashers and stuff so I
was like well [ __ ] night and then I
added a [ __ ] ton more movies to our
review list because I was like oh I
forgot oh but oh what forgot about that
one too it's like yeah we can do and
another thing we're gonna do is pry
tomorrow we're gonna get our AMC stubs
programs yes you guys don't know about
that you can pay like twenty bucks a
month yeah and see three movies a week
at the theater at the head of local and
we got it we got one close here yes so
for the price of two movies you can end
up seeing a white what 12 movies the
money you see in ten free movies which
allows you to see movies that you
wouldn't pay for I like most of that
[ __ ] I wouldn't go pay to see that but
if it's just on the program you're not
to get out of the house during the
afternoon you know you go down there and
you go watch on TV and then you don't
feel like right you know then you don't
feel like if it sucked you don't feel
like you've wasted you and I'll be able
to like update you know through my
through my little what do you call my
tablet you know I can get on my tablet
and update Tom shady movies you know to
give recommendations or say you see this
one I don't see this one so you know
some of my some of my group members will
like that and I just kind of would like
to see experience the dumpster fire that
isn't modern Hollywood because really a
lot of [ __ ] that they're pushing is just
[ __ ] garbage although what's funny is
that when we saw that last group of
trailers at the theater yeah the kids
movies actually looked more interesting
than the adult movies to me I have to
say I kind of want to
see that I wanna see and how the Grinch
Stole Christmas told Chris that looks
adorable
yeah some of the adult stuff is just
looking you just roll your eyes you know
like I don't know it's just kind of like
I don't know I don't think it's any
worse than it used to be because it's
easy used to be shitty movie some kind
of Chinese movie about a Megalodon a
half Chinese movies actually dominating
everything right now you know just goes
to show you that you know they suck well
and you know the new predator or movies
you know the new predator movie if
everybody's complaining about it you
know that it's like two movies pasted
together a good one and a crappy one
just leave the damn movies alone make a
good movie stop it yeah that was a good
movie I liked it a lot yeah I actually
sigh how's the clock result walls they
did a good job
yeah and I was skeptical I didn't think
that movie was gonna be any good but it
was I thought it's gonna be mediocre
yeah no it was excellent I like that
movie wouldn't mind seeing that again
yeah it actually was very good yeah so
we're gonna sign up for that program too
so so it might you're not paying us free
we're plugging this [ __ ] and I mean
payin us well it just sounded like a
good it's like I like I like going to
the movies yeah like I said if I pay you
know just by month then I can go a
couple times a week and got a nice
theater I want to go under nobody else
there yeah it's just me and you you know
DOM is smoking in the theater so we
might be able to like review some newer
movies or recommendations for newer boys
as well um so that's kind of so so we
got to come in and go in you know right
we got shutter for older movies right oh
they have new movies ooh and you know
Rob theatre stuff for just Jenny's
overworking herself as said Jenny man we
gotta get out of this house I am she's
overworked because she's got so much
stuff to do with these books and they in
the news there's so much cool [ __ ]
coming with the audio books you guys
don't know what was I trying to tell
them it's like I have to keep working
like crazy so I've got to get her out of
here at least three days a week during
the weekdays yeah so she don't look
crazy cuz I've noticed she's getting
kind of itchy bleaching out you know I'm
out like that you know so I gotta get
around I am though I am been in here
work of solid for about what I forget
like I forget words for things
like I'd be like hey bring me that
what's the thing that does the thing
yeah yeah he's like a cop yeah audiobook
for the second faceless mitosis build
should be done it should be on a market
price two weeks yeah I think I have well
I have seven more chapters I got most of
the long really long chapters okay so
I'm hoping to kind of get the audio down
and then I have to edit it and then you
have to upload it and then it has to go
like I said through the quality control
which usually takes about yeah and then
after that you're probably over the next
couple months you're gonna see a couple
of fiction compilations come up you guys
are going there's gonna be audio for
that too yeah I'm really Singh two of my
short story compilations and then I'm
going to be consolidating yeah some
other novels some unpublished short
stories and stuff like that into other
books
yeah I was looking at what Jenny was
offering you know in fiction and there's
a little bit here and there in there and
it's always in different little
publications and swims she didn't have
really rights to publish yourself all
that [ __ ] slap says Jenny maybe we got a
reconsolidate this product and it's
something that's easy to purchase like
you know like a one or two or a three
stop shopping process where they can get
this one this one and this one and get
all your [ __ ] yeah and then all the the
audio that goes along with yeah like I
said eventually I'm gonna record all the
audio yeah the names I've never done
that in general the way the market is
now people the name of the game is
audiobook reading is kind of gone out
for a lot of people but that's the same
people who used to read but don't read
too much anymore will buy an audiobook
because they'll listen to it on their
commutes though yeah well they'll lay in
bed listen to profit margin on it is not
we're not doing it that's what it that's
what they that's what the audio book
people give you yeah they say well if
it's this some long then this is what we
have to charge for it and this is your
cut yeah
so you don't have to sell as many of
them yeah it's it actually works out
pretty good it's like the highest profit
yeah it's a good problem margin honor
man you don't have to sell that many of
them so you can you don't have
- you say you can like target market it
and still make it make a decent amount
of profit off of it you know back in the
day you had to broaden everything out
and try to maximize exposure and water
it down to a general audience now you
can that we're gonna go right to here
get the people who like it and the
author gets the actual reward and not
the publishers yeah like it wasn't yeah
speaking of profit margin obviously I
usually say this but if you would like
to financially support the show yeah
that would be much appreciated
yeah we're getting new we're getting new
patrons all the time I want to thank you
guys fans because some of these guys a
real heavy lifters man they get $20
patrons we most of our patrons are 10
$20 patrons yeah that's some dedication
from that's some dedication yeah and we
really do appreciate it like I said um
so our newest patron is named Sean
so hello there Sean thank you very much
thank you and I'd also like to give a
shout-out to our superfan Eric who has
given us another very generous PayPal
donation that's right
so thank you and we appreciate drop 50
hundred dollars on you manage a superfan
the oh yeah oh we also have to bring up
the fact that those shirts are $20
patrons we're gonna send you shirts and
when's that buy two three months from
now yeah December 15 runs like them but
I've already got like I said I'm a sizes
do we have from people I think [ __ ] man
don't you guys want your shirts
confident tell us what shirt you want
what size like that and like I said to
if you would like a story read on our
Halloween special it can be horror
fiction can be a true story like true
paranormal or just true scary [ __ ] that
happen to you or can be fictional please
send it to grave cake at gmail.com I've
already got several and it looks like
it's gonna be a really cool show cuz
they're really cool stories so that's
gonna be a fun show I think we're just
gonna like you people's stories I may
repeat some of my stories we might have
some guests over yeah and we'll see how
that goes - like we'll see if we can
kind of chord and get some interesting
people for you guys
leshawna leshawna was over she's quite a
hit everybody like Shana Shawn is
awesome
yeah we love Johnny we might have some
people over yeah and also if you didn't
see our last movie review I forgot to
mention it was evil speak or yeah I
summon Satan using an Apple 2e yeah you
can't do this me man
maybe we should go get coffee now it's
gonna be our I actually thought about it
we had some left in the pot we should
have made somebody it's gonna be all
right
all right so since we like I said so
many people requested that I do the
NorCal rapist yeah
and it kept kind of getting shuffled
around but then just last week as a
matter of fact [ __ ] got caught yeah
through DNA just like they did watching
Golden State killers so I said so we're
gonna do this show about him and it's
also kind of serving as the news story
because it's like recent is [ __ ] right
he only just appeared in court for the
first time like his arraignment was
September 24th and that's yeah first
time he turned up in court he hasn't
entered a plea or anything like that but
they've matched his DNA to a couple of
the crime scenes and it kind of does
look like it's him yeah the guy is 58
years old his name is Roy Charles
Waller he was married he lived in
Benicia and he actually worked in the
Safety Office of the UC Berkeley campus
it's funny because I saw like news
stories about it and they were like oh
how ironic that he worked in the Safety
Office and he was a [ __ ] rapist but
he didn't he didn't have anything to do
with the safety of the students he
worked in he did like training programs
for like the forklift drivers and [ __ ]
like that like the heavy machinery
that's what he did so it was that type
of job so he I don't think he really had
much contact with the students now this
[ __ ] this alleged [ __ ] I
guess I have to say
cuz he's not convicted yet but he is
responsible they think for at least ten
eleven rapes that occurred around
California starting in 1991 it was like
from 1991 to 2006 now those are just the
ones that they know about right it's
like there there might have been some
other ones or some women that said
unreported or you know who knows what
happened but he apparently was going
around doing all this [ __ ] and he was
actually not a suspect until 10 days ago
when they found him on GED match just
like they did in the Golden State killer
case
they actually they haven't said what
relative of his it was but they they
actually you know made a family tree
from the DNA and then they worked
backwards and then they did the same
thing where they went through his trash
and got a straw and you know [ __ ] like
that and matched it all up and
everything so he had not been on the
police radar he was not a suspect until
they found him through the DNA so this
so the like I said it started in 1991
the first attack that they know of that
was him happened in Rohnert Park
I believe the victims name they had it
like there was a um there was a blog
that I read that had kind of a breakdown
of all the crimes and stuff and they
actually used pseudonyms but I saw this
woman on TV like talking about how happy
she was they caught him and her name is
actually Nicole Ernest pate because she
was there in the courtroom so I think
this was his first victim as they know
if she lived in Rohnert Park now this is
like really scary because this dude did
like some Golden State killer type [ __ ]
where this poor woman she comes home
from work she's like really tired really
exhausted she just goes in her condo and
forgets to lock the door doesn't lock
the door because it's not really that
late and then she falls asleep on her
couch and then she wakes up and dudes
pointing a gun to her head and then he
marches her upstairs he ties her to the
bed and he's there for several hours
raping her so she's like tied up with
duct tape apparently some of them have
blindfolds on - he always wore masks it
was usually a Mardi Gras mask or
sometimes a ski mask so and then he
would come in he would rape the woman
then he would go downstairs and go
through all her stuff like just you know
and steal [ __ ] that he would steal ATM
cards [ __ ] like that they they actually
had him on surveillance I believe it was
from might have been the 1997 attack or
might have been a later one where he was
wearing a Mardi Gras mask and he was
draining the girls account so I guess I
need a mask yeah
so they said they have surveillance
footage of that of him in this mask so
that's like so this that's the creepy
thing so that was the first victim that
they know of as I said so she didn't
kill her
no okay he didn't kill he's just a
rapist serial rapist oh he's a serial
rapist the NorCal rapist right that's
why they call him right yeah yeah so
sometimes they but sometimes I do kill
him
yeah he's not a serial killer then he's
a serial rapist yeah which is similar
but yeah he's not killed right the
shitty thing too is a lot of the women
that were victims said that he was real
sarcastic toward them like the first
victim she said that well the first
thing but before he raped her he like
had her all tied up and everything and
then he said so oh it's not gonna be so
bad
and like he put music on and [ __ ] like
that like it was a [ __ ] date or some
crap and then like afterwards before he
left the victim said that she said that
he said to her you shouldn't leave your
door unlocked somebody I'll come in and
hurt you oh I'm like he does on other
dudes too says hey man your fault you
know happens you know there's guys like
me out there god he's right there are
guys like him out there he's one of oh
my god okay so anyway so then there
actually wasn't um now she said that she
did report it to the police at the time
she said they didn't really believe her
and they didn't do much about it um they
were they thought she would have been
making it up hmm yeah they just thought
that it was so unlike
or something weird yeah it actually
happened in that way I guess I don't
know where this is this type of rate is
rare that's why we're talking about it
yeah mostly it's you know accusations
between people that know each other yeah
I mean a quick yeah acquaintance right
yeah a lot more or some kind of weird
rape yeah so the next attack that they
know was him actually didn't happen
until February of 1992 now this happened
in Vallejo so he's going from city to
city they're not all in the same city
now it should be noted that his victim
profile he almost always targeted petite
asian women or white women between 20
and 30 years old always they lived alone
or it was just two women that were
roommates you know what I mean
some of them were like college students
like I think a couple of them were UC
Davis students that live together in an
apartment
McDuff I think his name was Ben Macduff
or McDowell or yeah
that one he targeted I think was Macduff
he targeted some real small women too
because he could handle them a lot
easier yeah you know yeah I guess so
yeah but yeah so this second victim this
was in Vallejo um this actually happened
in the early morning she got it very
early in the morning to go to work as
she usually did so I'm presuming it was
still dark she gets out of bed she's
walking down the hall of her house
presumably to the bathroom and the dude
jumps out and like grabs her from behind
so he was like in her house like waiting
for they think that he might have been
like picking the victims ahead of time
and like kind of stalking them I they
didn't really make it clear I read some
newspaper articles from the time that
said you know that they that the guy
seemed to know details about them that
suggested that he had been stalking them
for some time prior to attacking so it
might be a case like I said like a
golden snake killer situation maybe
watching where he'd like watch him for a
few days a like before you know before
he set it up it was kind of like the BTK
you know he talked about he would go
into trolling mode and that trolling and
hunting mode of watching them was hope
was part of their ritual you know he
said he would evidently he liked that
just as much as the actual Commission of
the
yeah something like the anticipation of
it yeah it's like a whole was kind of
their version of foreplay
yeah but yeah so this second woman like
I said same deal he tied her all up now
she actually fought with him he was
wearing a ski mask and he had a he
generally would have a gun and a knife
she actually struggled with him and cut
him above his eye so it bled a little
bit and that made him very angry and he
actually did you know be able to
overpower her and then tied her up but
with the duct tape and did the same
thing raped her over several hours went
through all her stuff and everything the
next one happened in Martinez now this
didn't happen until 1996 there was like
a 44 year gap like I'm saying like I
said they don't know if he really did
wait four years or if there was other
ones in there that were unreported or
that they haven't linked to him or
whatever
now he's active yeah I'm kind of
thinking that that's probably he was
doing something else but he they just
don't know which was yeah so this a
surprise me if he's killed some of these
people because he might know about it
yeah right because usually this kind of
behavior does lead to serial murder this
is where serial murders come from most
of them come from this kind of [ __ ] well
look at some of them but maybe he wasn't
totally into it and tried to avoid it if
he could but would do it if he had to
yeah for all you know he's killed maybe
two or three yeah he may very well may
have right I mean because why like we
said that's how Golden State killer
started out he started out rapes he did
like 50 rapes that they know of and then
he started killing people
later on like he was raping for many
many years yeah this might have been one
of those ones where he wasn't too much
into the killing but he did do it if he
if he had to do escape right yeah and if
you're doing it regularly then that
means those those add up yeah before you
know it you're at three four or five
yeah you know but yeah so this happened
on Halloween night 1996 as I said in
Martinez this time he came to her door
pretending to be a trick-or-treater he
had a skull mask on and she opened the
door thinking it was like some [ __ ] or
jury yeah it can you imagine holy [ __ ]
took a treat oh by the way
a rapist yeah I know I was like freaking
me out it's gonna give me nightmares
but yeah so same deal he had a skull
mask on and came in there now the same
thing happened to her now in this case I
don't know if he did this in any of the
other cases but about 20 days after he
raped her he called her knew she
couldn't see his face because he had a
mask on but she recognized his voice and
he called and he basically said
something like now see some of the
articles said that he called to
apologize but to me it didn't sound like
an apology it sounded like he said
something to her like you know you're
really a good person you know or
something like that like oh it wasn't
your fault or it was or something like
that I don't know what the [ __ ] he was
trying to say pangs of guilt yeah I
think that's probably the case but um
either that or it's kind of twisted it
around maybe he had this twisted fantasy
that if you were to apologize she'd
forgive him he could go on a date with
her yeah that could be something like I
wonder if his wife knew about all this
crime huh I bet not they haven't like
talked to her she wouldn't answer the
door and like I said they this dude and
the wife the neighbors didn't really
they interviewed the neighbors and stuff
they it was a very nice house they had
nice cars and Mercedes and an Escalade
um you know he made quite a bit of money
he made $70,000 a year like at his job
and she I don't know what she did but um
the neighbors didn't they said they
seemed totally normal they said they
kept to themselves
they're like he just we see him out on
the weekends he's always like you know
tinkering with his cars and motorcycles
he was like a mechanical guy and you
know or he's out water into plants like
watering the Tomatoes but it's like you
know it's just weird but you know his
[ __ ] neighbor they interviewed one
neighbor like a woman that lived across
the street who I think was an Asian
woman and she was like I hope you
brought sin hell yeah so now the next
attack this happened I believe the next
one happened in Davis and this was in
1997 now this one was
he was wearing like a Mardi Gras mask
and they know the date of this one
because at 7:30 a.m. this is when they
got the surveillance of him with the
mask like at the ATM like draining his
victims account now the next one
happened like way north this one
happened in Chico and this one was I
think this was actually in 97 now this
girl this is actually how they ended up
catching him because he tied her up with
duct tape and all this other stuff now I
don't know if he had actually raped her
already
um and then like went to do something
else and then was coming back to do it
again because he would do that he would
be in the house for several hours now
while he was ransacking the rest of the
house she got loose and now he had left
a pair of scissors on the nightstand
with the hit that he was cutting the
duct tape with so he came back in and he
didn't have the mask on because he
thought that I presumably that she had
the blindfold still on but no she had
gotten loosened and sat up so he jumps
at her and she picked up the scissors
and [ __ ] stabbed him in the arm and
he just bled everywhere yeah that's what
I said I was like damn you go girl
so I let her live yeah he didn't kill
her well she and then she um she song
yeah so [ __ ] for a second
like she song cuz he cuz as soon as he
walked in and saw her sitting up he went
like that like in his hands in front of
his face like don't look at me don't
look at me so um so yeah so she stabbed
him in the arm and it bled everywhere
and he actually tried to clean up all
the blood like he took yeah yeah like he
took all of the bedding with him except
he couldn't clean it all up and I think
he left a pillowcase behind that still
had a little bit of blood on it I guess
he didn't see it so that's where they
got the main part of the DNA from that
girl stabbing him now I believe she told
him she got him to she's lucky she's
lucky that he wasn't as ruthless as a
lot of young by by this by the handbook
by the serial rapists serial murder
handbook he should have made sure to
kill her yeah because she saw it's me
she was very lucky that's one of the
things but I can understand why she took
the gamble because she probably assumed
that he was gonna come back in there and
kill her anyway yeah because she she
didn't know I mean you would have to
disable to assume that he's gonna come
back in there and kill you yeah some guy
that comes in and ties you up and rapes
you I'm like I'm assuming that go I
don't know what floor she was on had it
been me I wouldn't have gone after him
with the knife out of jump straight
clean out the window
yeah even if it was a two-story drop
well yeah it's gotta be that would be a
better bet on survival yeah then I just
go in there and try to find him with a
measly pair of scissors yeah I wouldn't
fight another man
with a pair of scissors yeah not if he's
of equal strength does made me better
just use your hands yeah oh no like I
said there's no advantage we tended to
target very small ramen so that very
much not enough and her favor to win
that fight yeah I would have just jumped
out the window by man much noises I
couldn't have everybody see me falling
with the glass and hitting the ground
and all that to make a huge scene so
he'd run yeah now evidently there was
another attack in Davis in 2000 but he
[ __ ] it up so I guess you know I don't
really know the details of that but
apparently the girl reported that now he
would do it sometimes too when there was
two roommates like sometimes he would
break in and he had a gun and he would
threaten them and he would tie them both
up and rape them both that happened a
couple of times and then there was
another attack they think this was his
last one happened on October 13 2006 and
so then at this point they didn't know
who it was like I said and I think the
the last one that happened in 2006 that
was actually two women I believe they
have a list on the Sacramento Bee
newspaper they did like a big long thing
about it when he got caught and they
have like a little map of where all his
attacks were they think it's 11 I
although I believe they're charged
trying to charge him with 12 I don't
know if they have DNA and all of those
but
the main source of the DNA was from that
girl
stabbing him with the scissors because
he bled all over her room so as I said
they have caught this guy he appeared in
court on September 24th in a cage
which you know that's nice he didn't
really say anything in his own defense
they gave him a public defender and so
and they they asked the employees and
stuff that knew him
like I said they thought he was like a
fairly normal dude they had no idea that
he was a rapist they don't think that he
targeted anybody at UC Berkeley
nonetheless they are going to review all
of their open sexual assault cases just
in case that he may have but he worked
there for 25 years and no one suspected
a thing
like I said I don't know if his wife
knows anything about it she has not
talked to the press and will not answer
the door what's the description on him
he is actually the one girl that saw him
and she was actually pretty close she
said it was a white male in his late 30s
early 40s and that he was like kind of a
kind of a hefty dude like he had a
prominent gut she said and yeah so when
they found him that's about what he
looked like he was 58 when they caught
him but yeah he looks like kind of a
schlub age love slubby white fella with
a big ol gut so we'll see how this goes
like I said the DNA seems to suggest
that this is him if he is convicted of
the 12 attacks that they have you know
that they're charging him with then he
will obviously get life in prison and
never be able to get out so let's kind
of hope that that happened so as I said
we're gonna keep watching this like I
said it's very recent he doesn't
actually appear in court again until
October 20th I believe so
we're gonna see how that goes but this
I've got a feeling about this guy this
is kind of awesome that they're using I
mean particularly California like all of
these I mean cuz this guy started
attacking people in 1991 and it took
them this long to catch him I've got a
bomb he's killed a couple of them yeah
it wouldn't show thank you honestly
I'll link him to some disappearances yes
I'd like that yeah I mean they they
didn't say anything about that
in France bun sounds pretty careful kind
of smart they probably have not found
the body so you had yessum body did I
think the I think he's gonna come under
suspicion of maybe being involved in the
disappearances of a couple of them yeah
although maybe not I mean that one girl
saw him and he let her live yeah but
yeah that's unusual but maybe maybe
after that he wouldn't tolerate that
kind of behavior and killed him or maybe
he killed a couple before that and then
decided he wasn't gonna kill and he kill
any of them more he couldn't sleep well
at night with it or something does he
let that one live there's no telling ya
I got a feeling based on what he does
I think he's killed at least one yeah it
would be strange like you said because
it does seem like a lot of serial
killers of that type start out as
serious and you know and then later they
will go on adrift in killers yeah
because like you said although you know
her seeing him like I said she only saw
him briefly maybe that had never
happened before any kind of panicked um
and like you said maybe he did kill
people after that cuz it was kind of big
I was like hey man that's too risky next
time I got I can't let him live I've
gotta kill him that's what yeah I'm just
losing everything could have been he was
losing sleep over that one that he let
go yeah he's like what if they catch ya
what if she one of she photos she you
know wonder if she figures it out
whatever about that DNA she can ID me
you know yeah I can't let that happen
again and then you know time passes I
guess I got away with that one I'm not
gonna let that happen again and then
later one of them Cesar uses I kill on
this one yeah something like that you
know and like I said they don't know
that you know the 11 that they have
listed on the page that's just the ones
they know about they said because one
thing that his victims said that he
would do was that like I said he seemed
to have stalked them cuz he knew like a
bunch of details about them so he would
tell them you know I know all this stuff
about you and if I find out that you
tell told anybody or called the police
or something
so some victims might not have like they
might have been scared that he was gonna
come back and didn't report it where was
he contacting them where was he first
seeing them I don't know nothing that
out
because the thing is that I mean he
moved around it seemed like um you know
he'd had the same job for a long time
but he kind of moved from town to town
with his wife but I don't know they you
know he didn't seem to target any
students at Berkeley where he worked too
hot
but yeah so he I guess he didn't want to
[ __ ] where he aged right so he did
target students a couple students at UC
Davis
but yeah it's like was he just like
driving around and seeing them or
getting fixated on that yeah I don't
really know it's like I don't know you
know if he traveled for work and he
would see people another place that
funded yeah like there's not a huge
amount cuz like I said they only just
arrested him and couldn't a lot of it
was a lie I've been heats are that day
went after got in and found out enough
about or just by being in her apartment
yeah he could claim to have been
watching her for a long time then yeah
how you word it you can make somebody
believe that yeah yeah but yeah so we'll
see how it goes and like I said GED
match catches another [ __ ] yeah
I think eventually they're probably
that's gonna be the future they'll
probably pass some kind of law law
eventually where you know you have to
submit DNA yeah well like I said they
just they they do it now where it's it's
just felonies I think that you have to
do it Berkeley in California I think
they're gonna do it I'm do it to people
as they're born yeah there'd be part of
your social security number I guarantee
it eventually that's what it'll get to
it probably will yeah right but all
right so we are going to can see how
that could be unconstitutional could
that be unconstitutional the thing is
they already take your G fingerprints
and stuff like that and nobody really
has an issue with that I guarantee
they're gonna say well you know you're
going to submit DNA at birth yeah yeah
and then well they're just gonna take it
that's what I mean though yeah yeah they
just take it and then they'll say it's
legal to take it and then every time you
go to the you know if you're an adult
and they don't have it when you go to
the doctor so we have to take your DNA
yeah eventually eventually everybody's
gonna be in a DNA database yeah yeah
though I don't know not everyone's in a
fingerprint database I don't think I
don't think my fingerprints are on file
prints aren't good enough
oh no yeah yeah they are because I got a
passport yeah right yeah give that a
score you're gonna get it yeah yeah so
any kind of security clearance so I
can't commit any crimes that I was going
[Laughter]
they make a lot out of fingerprints but
a lot of times they're not left behind
or they can't collect them it depends on
the scene yeah yeah cuz I gotta do swabs
and you can it's alright and then you
know if somebody gets killed in a place
where you're always there your
fingerprints gonna be there anyway does
everything to do with the murder
yes so there's you know there's a lot of
problems with fingerprints yeah all
right so we're about at the halfway
point now so we are going to take a
short break and when we come back I'm
going to talk about the serial killer
known as the Grim Sleeper yeah I'd like
to hear about this one yeah this is
actually a pretty interesting case and
it's also fairly recent they caught him
fairly recently so we will be back in
just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them mix
in the description
WWL com at 13 o'clock yes ago check out
our store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
of the old ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cut
they look really cute JT's got some so
thank you go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house is very much
haunted and will continue to be odds of
a long time all right we're back now
this is a serial killer that was
suggested by a couple of our listeners
and I had never actually heard of this
guy even though if he's killed as many
people as they think that he's killed
he's actually I believe he's the most
prolific serial killer west of the
Mississippi
they call him the Grim Sleeper because
there was a perception that he committed
a bunch of murders from 1985 to 1988 and
then there was a 14-year gap and then he
started committing crimes again in 2002
personally I don't buy that I think he
was killing people the whole time and
they just didn't link them to him but
and they're sure this is the same person
that's a lot of that's a long time well
yeah that's what I mean um well the the
problem Rises here's the thing about the
Grim Sleeper now like I said this this
spans a long time his first known crime
was 1985 they actually caught him he was
arrested in 2010 his name is Lonnie
Franklin jr. now he was sentenced to
death in 2016 he was convicted of the
murders of nine women and one teenage
girl so he is currently on death row the
unusual thing about Lonnie Franklin the
Grim Sleeper he's quite unusual for a
serial killer
according to statistics I saw well over
80% of serial killers are white males
between 20 and 30 years old
this guy is a black man who if 1985 was
his first crime didn't start killing
people until he was 32 years old now
there's a really good documentary about
this case it was actually made by Nick
Broomfield who
a British filmmaker and he came over
here and hung out in South Central LA
all the drug addicts and prostitutes
about the Grim Sleeper because I
remember this one this is why they don't
know who any people this dude killed
because the whole okay this whole
situation took place started to take
place in the mid 80s in South Central LA
during the crack epidemic yeah it's not
a normal serial killer all of the
victims were prostitutes or or drug
addicts of some type and for a very long
time
the LAPD didn't really do anything about
he they didn't even tell the community
that there was a serial killer yeah so
like some it actually took LA Weekly
like a reporter from LA Weekly to link
all the [ __ ] together and go and tell
the families of the victims it's like
hey this is a serial killer and the cops
have known since the 80s and they didn't
tell you yeah but from when I remember I
haven't read about the case and what the
cops perception was they the victim the
victimology the victim profiles was high
risk anyway in that area a lot of them
were kind they weren't all they weren't
sure if they if all these deaths were
linked they thought it might have been
stuff like drug debt happening you know
the organized crime semi organized crime
player hate all kinds of stuff because
in that area at that time a lot of
people were kid there was a lot of
killing going on yeah just a lot of
killing going on and yeah they think
there was actually more than one right
killer going but this guy they were not
really a lot of yeah they weren't I
don't think they were really convinced
that it was a serial killer as we would
think of one yeah I mean that's how I
remembered it like from what I remember
they weren't sure that all these deaths
were the same motive or the same person
they thought it might have been
statistical thing well now some of them
they did know were linked because the
same weapon was used was a 25 caliber
pistol and it was the same you know is
it the ballistics that's where the same
now not all of them were shot not all
the victims are shot some of them were
strangled 25 s man
2025 ACP pocket pistols were just all
over the place in those kind of areas
yeah that's the standard weapon of
choice they're just you know they're
only worth $25 $30 you know used on the
street but the [ __ ] up thing is
evidently I don't know if they still do
this but in the 80s the LAPD used to
have a distinction called
like when a crime happened to murder and
the distinction was nhi meaning no
humans involved that's when the victim
was a prostitute or a drug addict right
and so I'm like that's nice awesome LAPD
that's that's classy so like I said it
actually took people in the community
and journalists and stuff like that to
actually get the LAPD to admit that
there was a serial killer you know they
had to form coalition's and all this
other kind of stuff but um but they did
know from the mid to late 80s that there
was a single serial killer preying on a
particular type of woman now this guy
you know hold on no humans involved but
talk about the victim wasn't human -
that's what they meant
yeah well LAPD at that time in the 80s I
remember you know I remember what it was
like you know I'm kind of from the area
but I left an 81 82 LAPD was a
battle-hardened Police Department you
know yeah there was just it was a
shrinking population there's so much
violence going on that they just look
like a we can't control it yeah like I
said no they gave up trying to control
it really they were just trying to
contain it and that was kind of what was
got what had happened in Detroit Detroit
just became you know cannibalistic you
know it consumed itself a lot of it's
gone now you know the tore all the
buildings down yeah a lot of people list
left so it's almost abandoned compared
to what it was just dangerous areas you
know so yeah I think David these these
girls were just getting killed they were
like well we can't stop yeah they were
like they was know about it like I said
sometimes it was I mean he wouldn't even
like really hide it he would just like
dump them in alleys and [ __ ] like that
right and you know so like I said the
cops didn't know but they didn't tell
any
in the community they didn't really seem
yeah there was you know a lot of serial
killers obviously do target prostitutes
because for that very reason because
they know the cops are not really gonna
investigate it to the same degree as
they would have in someone else they're
in those places in times in the areas
the police be kind of just become a
defeated organization they just throw up
their hands going well there's nothing
to do yeah it does seem like that was
the situation that's why it took them so
long to catch it law enforcement can
only do so much you get there easily
overwhelmed you couldn't you can just
look at history yeah once the crime rate
gets to a certain level and they're just
overwhelmed and they just they can't do
anything they just almost retreat and
let it let it happen yeah but um as far
as they know his first victim was
actually named Deborah Jackson that was
in 1985 and like I said he probably
killed more people between nineteen and
then it was 1985 to 1988 and then they
think that he did a fourteen year gap I
don't buy that I don't think he did
either and I don't honestly I don't
think they're ever going to find out how
many people this dude killed I was in
prison during that time was he no um he
had been arrested before but it was
first [ __ ] like cars yeah I remember the
guys stuff I was in a car theft ring
pretty much he was a mechanic did steal
cars and break them down and sell the
parts off and he was in with a bunch of
guys and the other guys knew that he was
killing these or suspected that's the
thing like I watched that documentary
right and the thing is they interviewed
his friends and neighbors like everybody
the weird thing about Lonnie Franklin is
that everybody on the street knew him he
had he actually had the nicest house on
the block he had the most money like I
said he was a mechanic he ran a car
theft ring and [ __ ] like that so he
would give other people jobs and give
people money and stuff yeah and um
pretty man everybody knew him like he
was you know he would be out in his yard
like talking all his neighbors and [ __ ]
like that yeah so they're talking to his
light yeah like everybody thought he was
a great guy yeah and so the weird thing
about this documentary one thing I
noticed when I was watching it is you
know the filmmaker actually got it and
interviewed like a bunch of prostitutes
on the street and one woman that
actually lived that survived that was
attacked by him yeah and was
interviewing all his buddies and stuff
and his buddies at first we're all just
like yeah Lonnie was such a great guy
and bla bla bla and he was married I
don't think that the wife
I think the wife moved out at some point
but I think he was still legally married
he'd also been in the army although he'd
been out since 1975 but so what he would
do like he had a thing for photography
they weren't like pornographic really
but he would take pictures of women
naked like Polaroids and stuff and then
later he you know got a better camera
and stuff he was really into it and he
would show them to his friends now a lot
of the women were you know smiling you
know like hey pose but some of the
photos that they found later like the
women looked like they were unconscious
or possibly dead so not sure so some of
his buddies said that they're like yeah
he would show us these pictures of these
women and he showed us the pistol that
he had that he had used to kill I don't
know if the friends knew that he was
killing them I suspect that they may
have known but it was just weird how at
the beginning they're like we couldn't
believe it we couldn't believe it when
they came to arrest him
you know that they're like we thought it
was just car theft cuz that's what he
was always doing we couldn't believe he
was a serial killer but then like as the
documentary went on and like as he kind
of got more into talking to these
friends I feel like maybe the friends I
think they knew knew that he was at
least raping them and beating him up I
don't know if they knew he was a serial
killer I saw but I think they knew more
than they were letting on it I saw the
interviews with these guys yeah and
really you know it's not kind of the
normal serial killer environment where
you have people in some kind of secluded
farm area and inbred looking kind of but
they're kind of like everybody involved
is kind of like in a weird way
charismatic they kind of got that ghetto
charisma you know I mean they're all
they're funny that's what I'm saying
they're very funny and they have they
have really good communication skills
you know and I I think that I think that
I think they knew something well they
won got kind of admitted yes and we
thought something weird going on with
him
realized that he was killing them I
don't know it's a hard call and
something on a new but I think they also
kind of didn't care because this is a
violent era in a violent area and these
girls may have not been well-liked
anyway you know cuz they're mean to in
some in some cases so I think if they
did know they were like oh well [ __ ]
them you know I mean yeah they probably
mean ass get a hose you know they're
like that you know yeah it's kind of the
attitude you know she had it coming she
was bad that kind of stuff yeah maybe
not for prostitution but for the other
stuff that that she had done you know
because a lot of times they steal and
they you know they didn't they they kill
people too you know
sometimes but the interesting thing
about what they had done like his
friends were be like oh you know Lonnie
he was a good guy and stuff like that
and then they'd say something like but
you know if he got mad he got mad [ __ ]
yeah right so it was so I do kind of
feel like they I don't know if they knew
he was a serial killer but I'm sure they
suspected that there was something and
places like that the value system is
different okay you've got to be loyal
and good to your friends and reward them
and you also have to be ruthless to your
enemies so you know that you you won't
come under attack and your friends will
defend you because they know you will
stand up for them that type of stuff
so there was that element going on it
makes sense when you're in an area where
police just can't function yeah you know
the police would just give it up they
can't do well pretty much and the sad
thing at oh and I should say if you
watched the documentary I think it's on
I watched it on YouTube and you know so
I'm assuming you can just watch it for
free without feeling guilty about it but
um the highlight of the documentary for
me was the woman that she was actually a
former prostitute and former drug addict
and she actually befriended the
filmmaker and kind of took him around
the neighborhood and helped him you know
helped him like interview people and
stuff like that I think her name was Pam
she was a delight she was hilarious just
a hilarious hilarity tried to kill her
huh no you didn't try to kill her okay
these newer women yes
she knew him she didn't get attacked by
him but she knew people that had been
attacked by him okay now there was one
survivor okay her name was Anitra
Washington this happened in 1988 now
this is Rick repai she was just like
walking on the street and he pulls up
next to her in his Ford Pinto and he's
trying to give her a ride and she says
no she doesn't want a ride and then he
says something like this is why this is
why we can't be nice to black women you
know what I mean because we can't be
nice to you because she wouldn't get in
the car with him and finally but finally
like he convinced her to get in that
she's like okay fine I'll get in the car
and you know you can give me a ride and
then he [ __ ] shot her in the chest
okay so and then he and then dumped her
out raped her dumped her she lived
though okay so he's not killing them
based upon some kind of Street motive or
vengeance
he's doing it to random ones okay it's
just random just random chicks random
what's and the girl the girl that knew
him but he didn't kill her
he had a prior relationship with her
right he already knew who she was
is he killing ones that he'd done that
he doesn't know I don't really a man not
killing ones that he does know because
it's easier to humanize them I don't
know because I mean according to his
friends he used to like I said he was
married but I don't know how long like
because his wife she worked in the
school system I think and you know she
she was at church and everybody said she
was like super nice lady they actually
talked to his son's girlfriend at the
time and she was saying you know I never
saw the wife around the house I think
she was living somewhere else yeah so I
don't know just got sick of it and moved
out and just never divorced him or what
but all his friends knew he was super
into prostitutes he was super Intan he'd
bring him back to the house and like I
don't think he killed all of them but
like sometimes he would just take
pictures of them because he was like I
said he was into nude photography and so
he would like take all these nude
photographs of them and then sometimes
he would just have sex with them and let
them go
I've imagining because they said there
was [ __ ] prostitutes all the time he's
like super into prostitutes yeah you
gotta understand that during during this
time
in this place is almost like an
apocalyptic event so you know social
norms are not the same and yes is in you
know and so this is taking place in a
almost like a post-apocalyptic version
of LA yeah yeah no weird stuff happens
yes those conditions you can get away
with a lot more well obviously he got
away with a lot of [ __ ] before they put
him on death row yeah you know like I
said he started [ __ ] killing people
in 1985 that they know of
they know of he might have done some
before that that was just the first one
they know now like I said this woman
that I wonder why I don't know cuz he
had access to prostitutes he had access
to women cuz he's yeah guess I guess he
wanted to kill some of them Yeah right
but um cuz it seems like a lot of lot of
serial killers killed woman because in a
way they're also in sales yeah yeah now
but yeah he didn't really you know he
didn't seem have any problem in that all
right but you know um so like I said the
one that survived he shot her in the
chest and then pushed her out the car
and then raped her and then took a
picture of her and then took off and
left her there so but she actually did
survive now the interesting thing
because we were talking about DNA and
how it caught in Golden State killer and
how it caught the NorCal rapist this was
actually the I believe this was the
first case in California where they used
this type of technique what they did was
they had DNA from some of the crime
scenes and they he had been arrested
before Lonnie Franklin had but he his
last arrest was in 2003 and they didn't
pass the law that felonies had to give
their DNA until 2004 so they didn't have
his on file
however Lonnie Franklin had a son named
Christopher and Christopher was arrested
in I believe 2009 for a felony weapons
violation so they had his son's DNA hmm
so when they ran the DNA from the crime
scene through the match they knew that
you know they knew that obviously it
wasn't Christopher because christopher
was only 18 or 19 years old um so they
said oh well it must be a relative of
his
and that's how they closed it on the dad
and then they did the same thing where
since they had the DNA and they said
okay we have to check and make sure it's
Lonnie Franklin
so they had a police officer posed as a
busboy at a restaurant where Lonnie
Franklin was going to eat like for a
birthday party and then they took all
his like dishes and his beautiful for us
and stuff like that so I watched a
little bit of the the kind of trial or
the arraignment or whatever and it's
funny because his defense attorney
because it's like what are you gonna do
is you can't argue it's like this dude
probably killed all these people
the defense attorney tried to argue that
it's like oh well I didn't give informed
consent like to have the pizza crusts
and stuff and the judge was like there's
a little gray-haired lady she looked at
him like what the [ __ ] are you talking
through on your food away like you know
what I mean it's not yours anymore right
so it's like what [ __ ] worrying about
it so this was actually I think I
believe this was the earliest case where
this type of DNA match was made and
that's how they ended up catching him
now when they went through his house
they found thousands and thousands of
photographs of women now I believe it's
still there are a hundred and eighty
women that they don't know who they are
they don't know if they're if these are
other victims they don't know if they're
still alive somewhere they don't know
you know if maybe he didn't kill them
and they died later of you know other of
natural causes or drug you know drug
overdose or something like that or if
they moved away but there are a hundred
and eighty women that are the they found
pictures of in his house that are
unidentified like they don't know who
they are or if there are other victims
so I'm not sure so like I said some
people I'm he was convicted of ten
murders but I've seen some say well at
at least 25 it's probably more like 25
and I have seen some sources say it
could be closer to a hundred because
yeah you have to have evidence right but
they didn't now they also think that he
might have killed one man but they
didn't have the DNA
so they didn't they didn't put that on
the roster land making big they didn't
have enough evidence yeah they think
that maybe that guy was like a friend of
one of the girls that he killed or he
found out about the murders and then he
bumped him off or something like that
but like I said they didn't have enough
evidence for that one but they do think
he might have killed one man also so so
this guy like I said this is the [ __ ]
documentary it's crazy there was a crazy
documentary that was funny it what yeah
it was just like it was kind of sad
because um you know a lot of the women
that they talked to were kind of like
this one woman I think she was one of
the ones that had started the coalition
back in the 80s to you know to actually
have the LAPD recognized it was a serial
killer and to help them catch him and
stuff like that but she was talking
about how you know in that community
she's like you know I told my kids you
know from when they were very young
they're like if something bad happens to
you here's here's some phone numbers to
call do not call the police
they don't call the police because this
woman said you know it's terrible but
it's like you report a crime they'll
come and shoot you in the face you know
what I'm and read so much so we don't
they're like we don't call 911 one just
because we've had so many bad
experiences and it was just like really
sad but it was a non functional
organization right area and so like I
said it seemed like because there was so
much of this [ __ ] going on and because
you know particularly during the first
run of crimes in the 80s you know
there's the crack epidemic and it was
just like the the neighborhoods were
just yeah like you said just
non-functional there was like just
people dying of drugs and everything
horse was during that crack Ameth
epidemic I remember it yeah I mean you
know they were just killing each other
it was like a war yeah it's like a war
yeah and it seems like some think the
cops were basically just they just kind
of roped the area off and just allowed
them all to kill each other yeah like I
said this guy didn't want to die in a
crossfire you know right I mean this guy
they think killed between 25 and a
hundred women but he's not the only one
that I mean they're a lot because like
you said you know in that situation
there's gonna be some dudes that take
advantage yeah most of those Thomas
were drug-related in those areas yeah
fighting over drug money over drug
territory just arguments yeah
fighting over who had better shoes that
type of [ __ ] was ridiculous but like I
mean this guy like I said he really
seems like a different this is a
different yes entirely because he really
did seem to to me it sounds like he was
kind of an opportunist he's right he's
running organized crime with stolen car
parts he's got this thing for hookers
all right
for some reason another I mean he's
dealing with thousands of them but
sometimes he kills one yeah and you know
gets mad at her and kills her and it
doesn't matter there's no impact on him
because there's just no law and order
yeah cuz yeah he doesn't really care I
don't he doesn't seem to me based on
this evidence he didn't seem like a
sexual sadist he doesn't have a place
where he's taking her torture him he
doesn't it seems like it's just kind of
a spur-of-the-moment thing
[ __ ] you I don't like you [ __ ] bow Joe
I do now they did talk to one woman on
the documentary yeah who said that I
mean some of them he would do in his
garage right so what the photo shoot the
photo shoots and some of the killings
and some of the killings Wow
so this according woman according to
this one woman she said that he actually
took her in the garage and tried to slit
her throat but she actually ended up
getting away but I don't think she ever
reported it so an interesting thing too
that might you know that might lead us
to believe that he actually had more
victims was they said for a long time he
worked as a sanitation worker and he
could have just dumped the bodies like
in the landfill and they would never
find them like a lot of the ones that
they know about he just dumped him out
of his van like in an alley or she makes
you wonder why is it he's dealing with
all these prostitutes some of them have
no problem with him but every now and
then he decides he's gonna kill one
what's the difference I don't know it is
that some of them he wants to kill this
one when other ones he doesn't care
normal for Sirica usually they want to
kill all of them I don't know about that
he might have some kind of fetishistic I
mean the fact that he is so into
photographing these women in particular
like sexual physicians and he like I
said some of the photos that they found
in his house he took pictures
the women either when they were
unconscious or when they were dead they
couldn't tell so there does seem to be
some kind of fetishistic
element so maybe it's just like he likes
prostitutes but every now and then
there's one that just kind of strikes
him and I've taken away in a
particularly fetishistic sort of way
because like this one I'm gonna kill
this one because normally when you look
at her guys say like vtk yeah all right
he wanted to kill every single woman I
guarantee you that he saw he wanted to
kill them all yeah there were only some
of them he could actually get at ya and
when he did get at him he did kill him
yeah so it's almost kind of like this is
a different situation like he can get at
many of these women are almost all of me
you said a thousand of them but every
now and then there's a few of them that
he wants to kill yeah it makes you
wonder what's what is different about
those women that I'm talking about it's
it's it's we it's a it's a weird aspect
yeah it makes me wonder if there's
multiple motives yeah like maybe he
thinks she's got money in her purse
maybe he doesn't particularly like some
about her personality I think it's
probably that yeah maybe he thinks this
one is particularly bad and he wants to
kill this one and that'll make him feel
good to take this one off the street
that type of deal yeah it makes me
wonder if there's many motives
now sides that he's gonna gonna kill her
some of the prostitutes that they talk
to that it actually that had actually
you know serviced him I guess assume you
want to say they did say that he was
that he was a sadist like he would do
like he liked to do like torture he kind
of [ __ ] but he didn't kill those no yeah
some of them got that's would they get
away or you let him go
no he just they just let him go but he
just lets him go okay so now you know
all of them that's still weird
it is weird yeah why if you're into that
why do the sadist type thing and then
let him go and some of them you kill it
doesn't it's weird it doesn't make sense
yeah maybe he just was very disorganized
mentally it's I don't know is this just
dude just seems so weird it's like
there's so much about him that's unusual
yeah it's you know the usual from a
serial killer psychology yeah he doesn't
have the pattern point of view and I'm
also like I said I'm also really curious
about all of his friends and how much
they actually knew about it now some of
the friends speculated that his son
might have known what was going on I
don't know if they were implying that
the son participated because the son
according to the the son's ex-girlfriend
she dated him in high school and they
were both in high school and she said
that he was also kind of sadistic like
and crazy like he was one of those guys
that was just kind of like there's some
you know I'll kick your ass and not
shoot you in the face yeah different
about this particular guys okay so he's
very unusual he's falling into the FBI
definition of a serial killer just
because of the amount that he killed and
then yeah but and that sexual motive was
kind of there but in another way he
doesn't really conform to the known
patterns of regular serial killer
behavior it's almost kind of like it's
almost kind of looking like somebody
with a very serious head injury he was
in a post-apocalyptic environment and
occasionally gets pissed off he's got
some finished qualities to him but he he
doesn't kill them all
you know man but every now and then he
decides to kill one for some reason you
just get pissed off and kills her
yeah maybe every time like he loses
control of his emotions
yeah head injury type guy well yeah
that's not a real serial killer and you
know I mean if you were compared to the
other serial killers he's kind of like
an artificially generated serial killer
just behaves like one that does seem
like he might just kind of periodically
go into these kind of year like like
fugues or like rages or something and
kills her because like I said most of
his friends animating the neighborhood
were shocked that he got arrested in
Syria they said oh we thought he maybe
he got a rest of her carts at theft but
they all said oh he's a good dude
yeah he's helps everybody out and
because it sounds like he's basically
being satisfied he's not an in cell ya
got access to prostitutes he can even do
kind of fetish games to the prostitute
and let her go and not have to worry
about it yeah but then every now and
then he gets so pissed he kills one oh
yeah oh and we don't know how every now
in the world we don't see all of these
pictures they found in this house and
they
know who these women are weird in a way
it just sounds kind of like a thug in
the in the hood all right who's got a
bad temper who likes some fetish stuff
and maybe a suffered a head injury and
every now and then kind of loses his
ability to control himself emotionally
what seems like to me it doesn't sound
like the normal serial killer
development so far you know I mean where
you're killing animals at a young age
weird you know weird parental abuse you
know where child abuse things happen to
him and then they start exhibiting this
behavior or in their teens and you know
fire-starting or whatever it doesn't
really sound like they yeah he'd been in
and out of jail for you know theft and
stuff like that because right the
environment his culture and like I said
I don't know they they don't know if he
actually started killing people before
he was 32 years old that's just the
first one they know about so he might
have killed people before that and they
just never found them or you know they
never linked them to him you know what I
mean I would think that if he was like
other serial killers he was started this
[ __ ] at 11 12 13 by somebody else and
you know they didn't call the cops in
that area well that would have been the
70s there's probably a little bit more
police influence in the area of the
seventies yet I mean they probably have
turned him in to the police or somebody
would have killed him in an early age
for trying to rape somebody's sister or
something like that you know I mean yeah
yeah it's just it's just a weird case
he's oh he's a weird he's a weird serial
killer and like I said it's it's weird
because I never you know I write true
crime so I'm surprised that I had never
heard of it especially since he's so
prolific and they think that he maybe he
killed like a lot more people and you
know he's on death row now for 10 so you
know he's not getting out obviously but
you know they still the the FBI released
the hundred and eighty photos it's like
this really big I'll put it in the in
the video like a picture of it but of
the hundred and eighty unidentified
women because they want to know if those
women are victims if they're still alive
somewhere so they want them to come
forward so they can kind of maybe try
and pin some more [ __ ] on up because I'm
not sure I don't we don't have all the
facts I don't have all the
I don't know anything about his early
childhood you know I just got a weird
hunch that he's just not a normal serial
killer that he's maybe like not even a
real serial killer just might more like
multiple murderer yeah he did like I
said he seemed to start later and it
like it's it's just such a weird it's an
odd case yeah might be the kind of one
in a million might be head injuries or
brain damage involved yeah yeah well
yeah so I actually I don't remember who
it was that um that suggested that but
thank you for suggesting that cuz that
was like a fascinating case and I had
never really and I had never heard of it
I think a lot of people haven't heard of
it even though he even though he got
like a cool name the Grim Sleeper yeah I
remember watching and I remember
watching the documentary of their
documentaries quite amusing and actually
the documentary is called tales of the
great leaper like I said I'll put a lot
of characters that they interview quite
a music yeah they do actually like I
said that I think her name is Pam but
she's she's wonderful she was so funny
she just like cracked me up
it you know it's it's a sad
documentaries it's about for like a
[ __ ] serial killer but she really was
kind of a ransom you know from what I
remember his his buddies his friends the
guys you guys they were pretty real good
story yeah it's just that it's like I
said that was the weird thing about it
is like it starts out and they're all
just like he was such a good guy blah
blah but then is then as the time goes
on he's like yeah yeah all this DS
showed me all these guns and he showed
me these weird pictures of women and
they kind of knew a lot about it I'd
it's maybe it was a case of you know
they wanted to be in the documentary but
they didn't you know they didn't know
the guy so they were just kind of like
yeah he was a cool guy but then like the
more they interacted with the filmmaker
they were like yeah maybe we should like
tell I think they just knew the guy
because they were working with him and
they liked him and then he started
showing him weird stuff and they're like
wow wow pretty weird oh yeah she's hot
you know she's office used to be women
posing for a photo yeah cuz some of
Americana they look like they might be
kind of knocked out but that's not
unusual really you know for all they
know they were drinking and she you know
drinking that party and then she passed
out and took a picture but you know yeah
that may have already kind of had
permission to do that with her anyway
you know I mean they were partying yeah
it's something that was kind of nice is
something not really real alarming for
that you know for the situation you
yeah cuz you wouldn't say that you knew
like your name and stuff and they just
started showing you like stuff and you'd
be like yeah you wouldn't like
immediately Joan - well they're a serial
killer especially especially if you'd
known them for a long no they would be
more like boy he likes those hoes yeah
that seemed like fair yeah he likes him
Hosie
because they don't care the filmmaker
asked one of the friends that they're
like well did you think that was strange
that he had all these pictures and that
he showed them to you and I was like no
he's like he was just into women he's
like a lot of people are into women we
didn't think anything of it you know
it's like yeah I was a little weird but
it's like with your prostitutes and they
write you know they posed for photos
they you know right so he's like so we
didn't really think anything about it
you did I don't think you thought they
were killing it but yeah pretty weird
case alright so I guess we're gonna wrap
it up because we're probably getting to
this I can't believe it either
made sense did I make sense during any
of this yeah I think you kind of - tired
- I'm just got only had a couple of
brain parts that I'm you know I'm gonna
edit out because I lost my place looking
[ __ ] like that but yeah so I know it is
awful so remember if you like the show
to like share subscribe on all your
social media share with all your friends
tell everybody about us it really does
help a lot if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcasts top
wordpress calm and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account so you can
give a one-time donation if you'd like
to do that also check out all the
t-shirts and the tote bag we have for
sale on our zazzle store which is dazzle
calm slash 13 o'clock and be sure to
check out our last movie review which
was the 1981 movie evil speak and I
think that will do it for episode 111 we
will see you next time
death creeps through the door knows I'm
here
mr. faceless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]